[Music]
what do you make of a general tenor of
dialog in the country right now
I think it's ludicrous and
self-defeating I think that everyone
should reread Fahrenheit 451 because if
some people might recall reading it in
high school and they think of this the
tyrannical government that is forcing
the burning of books and of course the
some of their main characters but you
have these firemen who in charge of
burning books and what many people cease
to realize if they reread that book
which they will rediscover is that it
was actually the people in the beginning
who started the burning of the books
books that would offend any minority and
I don't mean that in a racial group
racial sense but a minority population
began to be burned and this is this is
very very very dangerous and I think a
very slippery slope where you have
effectively and I've seen a number of
people remark to this effect you have
the majority of smart people who could
discuss a topic and have the necessary
uncomfortable conversation in a rational
way opting out yeah because the personal
downside is so high that it outweighs in
the minds of these people who could
actually catalyze a lot of good the the
collective long-term good is not
sufficiently compelling to take an
almost guaranteed short term or I should
say immediate not short term it could be
very long term but immediate personal
hit so I think it's terrible I think
it's I think I think it's the the
biggest the thing that scares me most in
the United States right now is is by far
and away not what some leader from on
high would necessarily do to us it is
what we are already doing to ourselves
and that is disinviting brilliant people
from speaking at universities because
they might they might offer opinions or
positions that would make students
uncomfortable that's the whole point
yeah how are you gonna handle
macro aggression in real life if you
can't handle different opinions from
your own in an academic setting it's
ludicrous
so that yeah i get i get pretty lit up
about this because i think it's i think
it's a very insidious problem that is in
some ways being viewed as a solution and
it is certainly I think not beneficial
in in the long term at all yeah you hit
on a bunch of my wheelhouse stuff there
but I think the most interesting piece
of that is that what you're saying is
basically good people who could really
change the world who could change
people's minds get involved that they're
not because of the personal cost how can
we unfurl that I mean I've tried to
bring on people here and then and get to
some of this but I know and I can see it
sometimes with guests and I'm sure you
can too you get to a place where they
can't go any further they just there's a
cost of them talking about something
even if they're an expert in that where
they go now I'm viewing past that red
line and I'm gonna get into some trouble
so how do we bring that back for those
of us that want to have responsible
conversations and open discourse well
there's there's a word that I've been
experimenting with creating odd words
and inserting them into the common
vernacular for about two years now one
has made some rounds this is this is one
I did just for fun but you'll you'll see
where I'm going here so it's it's tell
adultery until adultery is when a
significant other or you watch a TV show
that you've agreed to watch together you
watch it by yourself that's that's tell
adultery said that but that traveled
here's the important point so that term
traveled all over the place and then we
were I was actually sitting in an
airport overseas with my mom and she'd
said oh here's a funny word you would
like and it was in a magazine and he'll
just tell adultery this is word I'd
created yeah so there's a word that I
currently I think that it's very if you
look at the the actors in this
suffocation of free speech or
discouragement at the very least of of
open discourse you have I think on many
sides what some people have called
social justice warriors who throw
terms like racist sexist bigoted of many
different types very loosely and those
terms can have lasting damage even if
there's no evidence associated with them
so the accusation itself becomes the
conviction and the term social justice
warriors not neutral in the sense that
it sounds positive so there really isn't
any linguistic punishment equivalent to
say racist that would discourage someone
from behaving in such a haphazard
fashion and in a way that can destroy
careers marriages you name it so the
term that came up in a conversation with
Eric Weinstein really really brilliant
mathematician physicist was this term
bigoted ear that I thought of so bigoted
ear is clearly not a good thing it
sounds terrible and it is someone who
calls others bigots for personal gain
and that personal gain it could just be
attention it could be absolving
themselves of guilt
it could be click-throughs it could be
yellow journalism and irresponsible
media just aiming for clickbait and
click throughs so I think that if bigots
here were were to become a real term
applied to people who use these terms
very loosely that it sounds silly but I
do think that words are what we lack
right now are effective words and labels
to discourage this this behavior so
that's that's one that has come to mind
as bigoted ear I don't think until we
have some type of disincentive from
behaving in a way that cauterizes or
just stymies free speech that we're not
going to get very far so the humans just
respond to incentives i don't think
humans are necessarily bad we're just
creatures that respond to incentives so
you have to figure out how to set this
the carrot or the stick sufficiently to
get the behavior you want yeah are you
saying we're almost like every other
animal on this earth that's exactly what
I'm saying
well I love the phrase bigots here and
I've used it a little bit but you know
we're gonna try something as of today
I'm gonna use a little bit of what they
call the Tim Ferriss effect which is
that when you know when you've had
people on your show usually their book
sales go up or their clicks go up or
whatever it is so we'll try a little
something I'll push out bigoted ear from
today going forward and let's see if we
get a little Tim Ferriss effect on that
because you're right you say social
justice warrior sounds like good thing
for someone that doesn't know really the
underpinnings of what's of what's going
on there exactly yeah all right let's
let's do it I'm up for it all right so
let's shift a little bit to your podcast
because we are both creatures of the
interview how am i doing so far by the
way you doing great you're doing great
okay all right very good
so did you always think of yourself as
an interviewer what made you want to do
the podcast in that form I always
thought of myself as an experimenter and
a teacher I always thought I was gonna
teach 9th grade actually because I was
very much influenced by mentors and I
think a very critical juncture around
that age of the 9th 10th grade kids make
a lot of decisions they don't realize
you're gonna take them down one
promising path or down a bad path but I
digress that that the point is that I
view interviewing as a tool in the tool
kit for extracting specific details and
tactics that I can then impart to my
readers who are I guess my students in
this case for replicating excellent
results that's it so I'm trying to tease
out the cliffnotes and interviewing
asking good questions asking good
follow-up questions letting silence do
the work at very specific points is how
you extract that gold and with without
the ability to interview well I can't do
the research that I need to do and the
podcast I never expected to do anything
it was really a commitment just to doing
6 episodes so that I wouldn't quit I
made that public pronouncement I would
do at least 6 episodes so that I'd be
held accountable and I wanted to work on
improving verbal tics I wanted to
improve the selection and follow up
related questions
and to become a more active listener
because I knew that even if the podcast
cratered or I didn't like it and I quit
those were skills that would transfer
everywhere else and this is something
that I actually borrowed ultimately and
really developed after Scott Adams of
Dilbert Fame and he calls it systems
thinking instead of goals thinking but
thinking of how you can win even if your
project fails and the way you do that is
by focusing on developing skills and
relationships that transcend that and
persist over time so that's that's
really how I thought about it and why I
got into the audio game but I was burned
out on books I want to take a break from
big books and here we are yeah I hear
that
I'm curious on the on the follow-up
question now I got a follow-up for you
which is how how scientific is that for
you so if you have a follow up prepared
someone hands you the answer that
basically you expected do you always go
to that follow-up or how willing are you
to to go out there because I find that
to be a constant battle sort of of me
wanting to just have a the natural flow
of a conversation versus I also want to
hit on certain things I don't want to
let them off the hook on certain things
I let people hang themselves that's my
method instead of shouting them down I
think that's a little more of your
method as well which is what I'm doing
at you right now very subtly oh yeah no
I feel like like an invisible [ __ ] is
strangling me at the moment on my back
you're naked choking me but no the the
the question I think has very personal
answers and the reason I say that is if
you study some of the people best known
for asking questions say Larry King so
Larry King very often goes in doing next
to no homework on his guests the
rationale being that the guest has no
familiarity I'm sorry the audience has
no familiarity with the guest and he
wants to start from where they are and
asking the basic questions then you have
say James Lipton up inside the Actor's
Studio
he has every question scripted in
advance and he never deviates from his
order of questions period end of story
he knows the answer in some form to
every question he's going to ask so you
have them on opposite ends of the
spectrum in my case
I don't necessarily have set follow-up
questions but I do have a handful of
questions which I've borrowed from other
people that very often can turn a
mediocre answer or a decent answer into
a great answer with a few extra details
and layers so you might have somebody
ask them a question they respond and
then you say what did you learn from
that
super fall an easy follow-up question
you can ask almost any time right uh how
did that make you feel that's another
really easy one that is kind of a layup
oftentimes and I don't go in with a
completely set agenda I'll give you an
example when I was interviewing Margaret
Cho comedian I thought we were gonna
talk about we've got from next week so
this is gonna be good for me oh she's
awesome she's awesome that's great so so
we were talking about the craft of
comedy and so on and handling hecklers
and so on you should ask her about that
yeah and we but we ended up bringing it
up and touching on addiction in comedy
drug addiction specifically in that that
took us to a really interesting place
and if I have been stuck on script we
wouldn't have explored it and that ended
up being just an incredibly fertile
ground for discussion yeah so I try not
to be too fixed but I do have my pet
questions that I like to ask as we all
do yeah have you ever been offended by a
guest that's one of the things that
people ask me a lot that how can I sit
with someone who maybe is against gay
marriage and I'm gay man how can I sit
with them and even if I hear their
rationale and they're not being mean to
me specifically how can I tolerate that
conversation and to me it's like I may
not like it but I do have to the whole
point of an interview is to try to
understand why someone thinks has
someone ever said something that truly
offended you I'm sure they have
nothing's jumping to mind but I'm sure
that that's the case and it makes me
think a bit of advice that I got from
Stephen Dubner
author of freakonomics or a co-author at
least he collaborates with Stephen Levin
and this I kind of went into a few
different aspects of this and tools of
Titan's but he said it's very important
to put away your moral compass in the
beginning when you're trying to
problem-solve especially when you're
collaborating with other people it
doesn't mean that
to absolve yourself of moral decisions
and judgments but initially if you if
you want to put if you want to generate
as many possible solutions including
non-obvious solutions or lateral
thinking solutions that you want to take
the constraints and assumptions that you
live with all day long and try to set
them to the side when I'm interviewing
someone let's say could be Glenn Beck
right now live in San Francisco if I'm
interviewing Glenn Beck if I'm
interviewing well let's just say General
Stanley McChrystal or Jaco willing so
both from extensive military backgrounds
versus someone who might view themselves
as a extremely let's say hyper
progressive slash liberal pacifist well
they're gonna have a voting opposing
viewpoints on a lot of things but what
what my eye view my job as extracting
politically neutral or apolitical
routines and habits and so on that
people can use so one of the mistakes I
think that we as humans tend to make is
that we throw the baby out with the
bathwater we say well I disagree with
so-and-so on X so I'm going to I'm going
to assume they have nothing to offer me
and that's a huge mistake and it's a
very costly mistake so whenever I'm
talking to someone I have some of my
friends I disagree with vehemently about
let's say nine out of ten of their core
beliefs let's just call them political
beliefs yeah but as long as they will
engage in a debate and not try to shut
it down with name-calling and nonsense
if they're willing to dance with that
and spar and admit when they've cheated
if they are able to absorb new
information and consider new evidence
and change their viewpoints accordingly
in some cases I have no problem spending
time with those people and in fact I
think one of the biggest mistakes we
were talking about echo chambers in
Silicon Valley is that if you surround
yourself with people who hold all the
same opinions that you do well
you're gonna get very comfortable with
comfort but it's not gonna force you to
consider save devil's advocate positions
that are diametrically opposed to your
own and I think that's an incredibly
valuable practice and some of my friends
are the first people to call BS even in
a group setting in it dinner like night
navall rava Khan I love the guy and I
feel better I feel every conversation we
have I come out of having improved in
some way you'll be the first person to
call me out if I throw out some position
or strong stance without evidence and
rationale to back it up yeah so and
don't you relish in that I mean I think
I think most people truly do and somehow
we've sort of been tricked or dumbed
down to the point where we think if
anything goes a little against us that
we have to lash out and that's so not
that's so not fertile ground for for
growth no I agree yeah I mean I think
that one of the things I try to do at
least once a week but preferably much
more than this is to be the weakest
person in the room at something I want
to be in the room and it's going to lead
me probably to feel insecure maybe
insufficient but whether it's training
in a sport or picking up a new skill or
sitting down in a room where people are
discussing could be anything molecular
biology or politics where I feel like
I'm in over my head and that is how you
average up and I think you also average
up by surrounding yourself with people
who can intelligently debate and not
just use rhetoric to try to corner
people but to actually go toe-to-toe
with logical arguments at least based on
their own assumptions I think that's if
you want to become smarter and by the
way like the race doesn't go to the wall
the fittest in this situation means most
adaptable and I think that is is the
cornerstone of everything else yeah what
do you make of this new idea that
everyone seems to think that they have
to have an opinion
on everything like if you look at Russia
right now whatever is going on with
Russia and the election we don't have to
get into the minutiae of it but it seems
to me that people who I've never seen
talked about Russia before who I don't
think are particularly informed or smart
everybody's got an opinion and must
share that opinion I'm for the free
speech part they can do whatever they
want but just this idea that everyone
always has to share everything yeah I
mean they probably couldn't place Russia
on a map yeah so the the the the great
gift and curse of the Internet is that
everyone has a voice now that means
every smart people every smart person as
always also means every idiot has a
voice and more and more and this is in
part because I go out of my way to
expose myself to people who knew more
about many many domains than myself I
find myself it's not pleading the fifth
it's different I will say I don't think
I'm qualified to have an opinion on this
I say that in the last few years my the
frequency of me saying that has just
skyrocketed because I don't want to have
a strong opinion where I can't back it
up and so I think that it's fine to have
an informed opinion but there's informed
confidence and then there's uninformed
hubristic stupidity so I would hope that
people would lean more towards the
former and away from the latter but alas
in in a in a media culture where the
eyeballs and years tend to gravitate to
the most outlandish argument imaginable
it seems that that tends to get a lot of
the attention but yeah are you ever
tempted by that that click portion of
this you know we know very easily we
could title our things differently and
probably triple the clicks we could use
misleading thumbnails I mean you know
all the games of the digital world
plenty of people are playing have you
ever been tempted to do any of that
stuff you know I in the beginning in the
beginning I mean when I had my
first blog and if people out there want
to laugh their asses off they can look
up just Google Tim Ferriss first blog it
is the most hideous disorganized
terrible mess you've ever seen on the
internet it's it's really atrocious and
at the time I was told I had to mimic
this person and how they did acts I had
to do 12 posts a day before noon to have
any hope of a B and C it was there all
these arbitrary rules and it was a
me-too game of mimicry so I I did try
listicles and all sorts of stuff that on
some level works but it wasn't me and it
had no evergreen value so I've I've been
rewarded thankfully for trying to put
together really comprehensive material
that lasts not only lasts multiple years
but the real estate if we're talking
about print let's say actually goes up
over time so my my my Google real estate
appreciates over time and some of my
most popular posts were written five six
years ago and they still drive the
majority of traffic to my blog so I have
been tempted at points to do that but
ultimately my fans oh I'm very fortunate
very smart generally very well educated
they are very vocal so if I try to pull
any of those shenanigans I get punished
very quickly for that so it's it's good
to be held accountable
[Music]
you